- [Narrator] Ukraine has been targeted
by barrages of Russian drones
and missiles in recent weeks.
But a multi-layered air defense network,
bolstered by many Western donations,
is allowing the country
to repel many of them.
(gunshots cracking)
Roughly 90% of strikes in May
were intercepted according
to Ukrainian officials.
However, some military analysts say
Russia is adapting its strategy
to try and evade these defenses.
So as attacks intensify,
here's how Kiev's air
defense systems are working
to intercept strikes from the sky.
This video shows one of
dozens of aerial bombardments
taking place in Ukrainian cities.
The Russian tactic is to
weaken Kiev's air defenses
by exhausting their
supplies of ammunition.
That's according to defense experts.
So how is Ukraine responding
to threats from the sky?
Let's take a closer look.
Ukraine began the war with
an extensive stockpile
of Soviet-era air defense systems.
Now they're working in
tandem with weaponry
supplied by Kiev's allies.
That includes the US
supplied Patriot and NASAMs,
and German-made Gepard.
The air defense systems
follow a series of steps
to take down threats.
That process starts with using a radar
to scan the sky for incoming attacks.
Then if a threat is detected,
the firing system is launched
to try and blast away the projectile.
The Gepard system has
a range of 3.5 miles.
Defense experts say it's normally used
against slower moving targets.
In this footage, Ukrainian officials say
a Gepard system can be seen
targeting Russian drones.
Military analysts say the red dots
appear to be tracer rounds,
which are fired to create
a trail of light towards the
target, making it more visible.
While systems such as
the Gepard and NASAMs
can take care of low flying
cruise missiles and drones,
Ukraine has struggled to
counter ballistic missiles.
To target those, Ukrainian
forces have looked
to the US built Patriot.
Two of the systems were
delivered in April.
In an interview with
the Wall Street Journal,
Ukrainian president, Volodomyr Zelensky,
outlined its importance.
(President Zelensky
speaks foreign language)
- [Narrator] The sophisticated system
can detect incoming threats
more than 100 miles away,
and it can aim and fire
at identified targets within seconds.
But even when Ukraine
manages to blast missiles
and drones from the sky,
there are hurdles to overcome.
Falling debris can bring
death and destruction
to residential areas,
and remaining fragments
can start fires.
In addition, there's been
concern in Kiev and Washington
over how long dwindling
ammo stocks can last.
Ukrainian President Zelensky
said he's asked allies
for extra support.
That's as military analysts say
Russia is shifting its strategy,
which could lead to more air strikes
breaking through Ukraine's defenses.
Techniques include flying drones at night
and at a lower altitude to
try to avoid radar detection.
(projectiles booming)
As the war continues, air defense assets
could play an important role
in the counter offensive.
(President Zelensky
speaks foreign language)
- [Narrator] Military analysts say
Ukraine will need to balance
the air defense needs of
civilian infrastructure
with the need to protect its
troops on the front lines.
So far, neither side has been
able to take firm control
of the skies over Ukraine.